A couple years ago I had the opportunity to travel to Beirut Lebanon to give a talk.
It was an amazing experience. I fell in love with the city, the culture, the heritage and
most of all the people.
In the course of my initial visit I was introduced
to a remarkable woman named May El Khalil.
She's the founder of the Beirut Marathon,
which has grown into the largest running event
in the entire Middle East.
In 2015 May invited me run the marathon and
I jumped on the chance to return to Beirut.
Burrito bowls. Water. I’m all set to board.
My impression of the Middle East had been
historically informed by mainstream media
as this very unsafe, dangerous corner of the
world where tensions run high and anything
can happen anywhere at anytime.
What I found instead was an incredibly beautiful,
dynamic city overflowing with history and
teeming with warm and sophisticated people
with tremendous hope and resolve for a better
Lebanon.
Sure – the city is far more threadbare,
worn, war-torn and strife-riddled than its
pre civil war, Paris Of The Middle East heyday
in the mid-1960’s. But it remains a truly
incredible place.
Pretty jet lagged. But I’m going to go out
for a run.
Run done.
So we’re in a cab. Where are we going? This
is Isabelle. Hi Isabelle. Are you running
the marathon on Sunday? Your first time? Me
too! Give me five.
So there’s a lot of people who have been
asking me, “why are you going to Beirut
to run a marathon? You can run a marathon
anywhere. Why Beirut?”
The reason I am here is because I believe
running can change the world. I believe that
running can be a very powerful instrument
of peace – particularly in a place like
Lebanon where strife – both political and
religious – runs deep and has been going
on for a very long time.
May El Khalil: Hello Rich. It is wonderful
to have you with us.
May El Khalil TED Talk: “For one day a year,
we truly stand united. And that’s when the
marathon takes place.”
Rich Roll: An avid runner herself, May was
inspired to start the marathon after a near-fatal
accident that left her in a coma. Countless
surgeries, hospitalized for two years, she
would never run again.
But the resolve from this personal struggle
motivated her to give the gift of running
to a city and a country itself struggling
to survive.
May El Khalil: I needed to dream big, I needed
something to take me out of my pain. An objective
to look forward to.
Rich Roll: Sunni, Shia, Armenian, Palestinian,
Egyptian, Syrian, Jordanian, American –30,000
runners from all walks of opposing political,
cultural and religious perspectives congregate
annually, set aside their differences and
just run – a literal moving peace procession.
May El Khalil: And when the gunfire went off,
this time it was a signal to run in harmony.
It is a platform for hope and cooperation
in an ever-fragile and unstable part of the
world. From Boston to Beirut, we stand as
one. After all, peace making is not a sprint
– it is more of a marathon.
We begin in Lebanon, where the Islamic State
has claimed responsibility for one of the
worst attacks to hit Beirut in years.
Panic and confusion in Beirut.
As of last count has killed at least 43 people,
wounded over 200 more…
Just 2 days after the marathon, violence returned
to Beirut when ISIS attacked a neighborhood
just down the street from my hotel. A neighborhood
I had walked through just a few nights prior.
I was devastated.
Beirut was no longer this distant, foreign,
unrelatable place that just pops up on CNN
from time to time. It was real. And Its people
were my friends. That’s what travel does.
It breeds empathy.
But when I reached out to my new friends,
I was met not with depair, but rather an even
firmer resolve to forge unity
To echo May El Khalil, making peace truly
is a marathon.
But it’s a marathon worth running.